pour que les dames la ministre la parole
et à monsieur yves fromion le supplice
de la défense notre assemblée a rendu un
hommage solennel aux machettes des logis
fabien jacques bon pour la france au
mali dans l'explosion de son engin
blindé ce drame me conduit de fait à une
double interrogation vous engagez vous
monsieur le ministre à examiner
sérieusement comme je voulais déjà
demandé la perspective d'une
accélération significative du programme
scorpion destiné à équiper nos armées et
nos armées terre d'engins moderne et
convenablement protégé en remplacement
du parc vétuste dont elle dispose je
souligne qu'au rythme actuel de la
programmation scorpions nos soldats
utiliseront encore en 2030
des engins blindés de plus de 50 ans du
modèle de celui dans lequel fabien
jacques a trouvé la mort il y à là
matière à se remettre en cause
je vais également vous interroger sur la
mise en vente de la société renault
trucks defense appartenant au groupe
volvo à laquelle vous avez confié une
part importante de l'industrialisation
du programme scorpion dont je viens de
parler
nous savons que des groupes financiers
se sont déclarés intéressés de même que
des groupes industriels notamment
étrangers il est impensable que l'état
français ne se mobilisent pas pour
prendre la main sur ce dossier
en effet ftd assurent 90% de la mobilité
de notre armée terre et 100 % de celles
de nos forces engagées au mali nous le
fabriquons plus d'armements petit
calibre depuis une décision du
gouvernement jospin vous même monsieur
le ministre avait engagé nexter dans une
alliance pour le moins incertaine avec
le groupe allemand kmw en conséquence de
quoi nous avons perdu toute autonomie
industrielle dans l'armement terrestre
et nous sommes le seul pays européen à
l'avoir fait notre indépendance est de
fait mise en cause c'est pourquoi les
républiques exil que le parlement soit
associée aux initiatives qu'il vous est
demandé de prendre pour que la cession
de rtd si vous deviez l'a confirmé sa
conforme aux intérêts majeurs de notre
pays vers si la balle est amusé jean
marc gini secrétaire d'état chargé des
anciens combattants et de la mémoire
monsieur le président monsieur le député
fromion je constate que d'autres pays
aime toujours la polémique et vous
particulièrement mais dans la période
actuelle et sur laon et se vend ici de
défense cela ne me semble me semble
particulièrement infondées
vous savez que le ministère de la
défense était en inde récemment pour
signer un troisième contrat rafale en 18
mois et que et que cela fait suite à la
victoire de se dessiner des sons
d'australie pour le plus gros programme
export de l'est de l'histoire de france
tous secteurs confondus et nous vivons
et nous vivons des années records en
matière d'export
nous avons trouvé un secteur de défense
qui est exporté pour 4,7 milliards en
alors l'an dernier en 2015 on était à
plus de 17 milliards soit quatre fois
plus ce sont ainsi des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois qui sont créés dans
le secteur français des industries de
défense dans le ministère de la défense
entretient par ailleurs l'excellence
technologique
vous comprendrez donc que nous soyons à
disposer sur joe recevoir des leçons de
patriotisme
j'arrive le drian a eu l'occasion en
main deux reprises d'expliquer la
situation sur le successeur du famas il
a répondu déjà deux fois dans cette
assemblée sur morpho et airbus
vous évoquez la vente par le groupe
volvo annoncé le 4 novembre qui concerne
1300 employés majoritairement en france
renault trucks defense et à travers lui
les marques pour un réac ma tatie ces
dernières années constitue l'actif le
plus important dans cette activité
rtd jour notamment vous l'avez dit un
rôle essentiel dans le projet scorpion
de modernisation du renouvellement des
véhicules blindés de l'armée de terre
française ou dans la réalisation des
véhicules
c'est pour cette raison que nous tenons
à vous rassurer nous serons
particulièrement attentifs à la façon
dont sera conduit ce processus de
cession alors rassurez vous monsieur est
trop bien l'industrie des fonds c'est
une chance pour l'avs pour la france et
nous